[Musique]
Tout d'abord, tout homme ici qui veut
s'éloigner peut le faire en sachant qu'il est le
meilleur d'entre nous, il doit y avoir maintenant il n'y a
pas de soutien au sol la blessure subie
nous sortons sans faire d'erreur
à ce sujet  vous devez reconnaître le fait que
si nous n'avons pas le drapeau sur notre
épaule, vous ne pouvez pas reprendre votre
vie normale après ce soir, tout ce que
nous avons fait au cours des 17 dernières années, rien à
montrer,
vous avez été abattu cinq fois pour votre
pays et vous ne pouvez même pas vous permettre d'
envoyer vos enfants à l'université si nous avions
accompli les choses que nous avons
accomplies dans n'importe quelle autre profession que nous avons
fixée pour la vie Je suis votre maître la
question est de savoir si nous pouvons enfin utiliser nos
compétences pour  notre propre avantage
nous allons amener Gabrielle mon équipe
ici il a plus de 75 millions de dollars en
liquide si vous ne partez pas pour toujours
après avoir fait votre déménagement
nous sommes morts nous devons chasser rapidement
[Musique]
c'est toujours un peu difficile  et tu penses que
ça va être
nous n'aimons pas ce
n'est pas ce que  Je me suis inscrit car beaucoup
de gens vont venir donc ça passe
par
toi